well who knew that today it would be NFL
football at the center of a major major
controversy involving Donald Trump and I
guess this sort of started to blow up a
few days ago when Donald Trump called
NFL quarterback Colin Kaepernick son of
a [ __ ] because he has been peacefully
protesting by not standing during the
national anthem which is played before
NFL football games and there's just so
much wrong with every aspect of how this
has absolutely exploded and even before
the specific kneeling at the anthem
thing became an issue
there have been debates about free
speech that have become incredibly
polarized and really pretty unhinged in
the u.s. and there's a few reasons why
that's been going on number one and
we've talked about this is the major
confusion around what the First
Amendment actually means usually the
First Amendment is not at all a factor
in the conversations people have about
free speech and for more about that
specifically you can check out my
interview with attorney Burt newborn
who's an expert on the First Amendment
that's on youtube and in the archives
for our members even when we can get
past the issue of the First Amendment
there is still confusion from people
about the right to speak whenever you
want and wherever you want versus being
quote censored now as an example of
where people don't understand that just
because you have a particular college
that sometimes has speakers doesn't mean
that they have to have you as a speaker
to avoid being a the practicers of
censorship or violations of three free
speech no one has a right to speak at
any college that they want to and even
when we can get past that confusion
there's still a total misunderstanding
of the reality that free speech is not
freedom from the consequences of that
speech you might be able to say whatever
you want but there can be consequences
to doing so and that's okay also now
shockingly the Colin Kaepernick thing
has blown up despite not really being
controversial at all I mean in the
United States there's nothing legally
wrong with not standing during the
national anthem
there's nothing morally wrong with it
either as that is sort of the
prototypical nonviolent Pro
type that I thought our country was
founded upon and one argument is what
Colin Kaepernick is being disrespectful
to the military members who fight for
our flag now they fight for us to have a
country where people can express
opinions like Kaepernick is doing by
kneeling during the national anthem and
the height of hypocrisy is the people
who complain about oppressive political
correctness and then they say Kaepernick
should be fired for kneeling during the
anthem because that's wrong demanding
someone stand during the anthem is the
same type of heavy-handed normative
political correctness that the same
people claim to oppose so anyway Trump
is full in with this nonsense gave a
speech in Alabama and he went off topic
into a rant about the NFL and referred
to players who kneel during the anthem
as sons of [ __ ] take a look at this
nyeeeeehhh and everyone in this arena
tonight are unified by the same great
American values we're proud of our
country we respect our flag
[Applause]
when you love to see one of these NFL
owners when somebody disrespects our
flag to say get that son of a [ __ ] off
the field right now out he's fired now
remember that according to trump there
were fine people on both sides of the
neo-nazi rally yet NFL players who Neal
is a sign of activism or sons of [ __ ]
which is also calling their mothers
[ __ ] which is probably not that
surprising coming from Donald Trump
there are fine people fighting for
racial separation and the sons of
[ __ ] are the ones activating against
racial inequality also you got to love
it when Trump is wrong on multiple
levels so of course there's the level
that you laid out there but also Colin
Kaepernick the quarterback whom a lot of
this focus and drama is centered around
yeah doesn't have a job right now
he's a pretty good quarterback by all
objective measures the whole reason that
he's a free agent is because no team
will sign him because they're afraid of
the backlash it's going no doubt about
it and many NFL players are not happy
with this a ton of them tweeting over
the weekend New England Patriots owner
Bob Kraft who's known to be a friend of
Donald Trump's put out a statement
slamming these comments the NFL
Commissioner Roger Goodell --zz office
did the exact same thing you had Jaguars
and Ravens players kneeling during the
anthem in response to Trump's criticism
20 of the New England Patriots took a
knee countless NFL players hundreds of
players total the NFL consider for a
moment is a totally militaristic
corporatist
and by and large right-wing Haven in
terms of its ownership structure and
they're more or less unifying against
the comments from a Republican president
consider what that means even
recalcitrant elements of the Republican
Party have been speaking out in favor of
the players and against Donald Trump and
this is moronic nonsense in a number of
ways first is ideologically then is
Trump's hypocrisy which is often there
as I mentioned already the right
complains about black lists against
conservatives in different industries or
in Hollywood or at
Google and then they want people fired
for expressing political opinions
through nonviolent action it's sort of a
blacklist for anyone who kneels during
the national anthem does anybody see the
glaring hypocrisy here then they
complain about oppressive political
correctness but again say that you
should be required to stand during the
anthem because it's wrong not to and
it's disrespectful
this is enforcing their own version of
political correctness and this may come
as a shock to some people in our
audience Pat you cannot be a fan of this
protest method kneeling during the
anthem but recognize that it is
absolutely the type of non-violent
political speech that we that the
country was founded on and recognized
that the president dictating people be
fired for it is absolutely atrocious and
he also went after the NBA this weekend
too because apparently he did nothing
better else to do and he said that
usually after an NBA team wins a
championship they go to the White House
and there's this whole big ceremony and
everything of course ended that
invitation for the Golden State Warriors
right so of course you know the Players
Association is behind them LeBron James
called him a bum it's just a bad
political strategy too because a lot of
people in the middle of the country love
their sports more than they love
politics they're gonna choose the
Warriors and Kaepernick over Trump I
think for the most part I think you're
right and Steve Kerr the coach of the
Golden State Warriors I don't know if
you saw it Pat but he had an amazing 90
second comment about all this and that I
mean it just I don't know who Trump's
picking a fight with and the argument I
saw from a defender of Trump was listen
people have been pulled about whether
they support kneeling during the
national anthem and something like 60 to
80 percent of Americans believe it's
wrong to kneel during the national
anthem thus Trump is actually on the
right side of this you can be against
kneeling during the national anthem but
still recognize that it's
constitutionally protected and it is the
right of whoever is choosing to do that
to do that and not to be fired for it
and I think that's where maybe Trump is
miss reading it yeah I think a lot of
people understand that it's just a
symbol it's just a song but to those who
think that it's more valuable and
important than that I think they
understand as well that this wouldn't
get much of an attention if he was to do
it in some other way if he was to
approach
when the cameras weren't rolling when
the national anthem wasn't playing
there's no way we would be talking about
this right now and by the way what's the
point of fighting for our freedoms
around the world with the military all
that stuff if then people don't get to
choose how they use that freedom however
they want and this is the president
calling for the firing of employees of
private businesses that's not exactly
the freedom that I thought the right
wanted and then of course Pat mentioned
this earlier when it comes to Trump and
respect and service Trump is framing his
position here as the moral position as
the patriotic position it's duty to
country and respect for our troops Trump
attacked the gold star family Trump said
he didn't think a former prisoner of war
Senator John McCain was a hero because
he was captured and according to McCain
over the last 24 hours
he's never apologized to John McCain for
that Trump said that avoiding STDs
through risky sexual encounters was with
women was his own Vietnam and Trump
avoided the draft multiple times because
of bone spurs that he couldn't even
remember in which what he had them when
asked about it years later and it's
often Trump who's doing the not
patriotic thing when there's a flag or
anthem around remember at a Republican
debate when Donald Trump did not have
his hand over his heart
it was Trump during the Pledge of
Allegiance or anthem or whatever it was
Marco Rubio had his hand on his heart
Ted Cruz had his hand on his heart ben
Carson who usually sleeps through these
things had his hand on his heart but not
Trump Trump doesn't know or admit to
even knowing why these players are
taking a knee he claims it's
disrespectful to law enforcement and the
military what about flying the
Confederate flag isn't flying the
Confederate flag as disrespectful to the
actual flag of the United States as just
kneeling during the anthem and the last
point I want to make on this trumps
coming for your health care right
Trump's coming for your health care and
he sends a dozen tweets about kneeling
during NFL games Trump's been silent on
Puerto Rico Puerto Rico we're talking
about Americans in Puerto Rico who have
no power they are lacking water after
getting hit with two hurricanes and
instead of a dozen
it's about how Trump is going to help
Porto Rico it's a dozen tweets about
athletes kneeling during the national
anthem and remember he made these
comments when he was endorsing the
Alabama Senate contender Luther strange
to you complete ad-lib here yeah oh and
and it seems that anytime trump comes up
with these little ideas they end up
completely imploding and III you know we
know enough about Trump's personality to
assume he thinks he's writing all this
Bob Kraft 200 players this that the
other person saying yet Trump just wrong
about this Trump will rationalize it and
say no no here's why I'm actually the
one who's correct and the truth is there
are enough people in this country who
side with Trump and don't understand the
nuances of the First Amendment end a
free speech and of censorship and of
private companies being able to make the
employment decisions that make sense for
them that this may actually not be
something that really drags down Trump's
approval rating we'll see it's actually
shockingly I mentioned last week that
Trump's approval rating has sort of
ticked up a little bit
it's ticked up a little more now up to
40% as of this morning in the Gallup
daily tracking poll but we will see what
those numbers look like closer to the
end of the week okay I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the shows on Twitter at David
Pakman show what do you think of all
this what's really the core issue that
is at play in Trump's criticism of
kneeling during the national anthem the
video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership